We're learning what
Tucker Carlson texted
that was so worrisome
to Fox executives
and the board
that it reportedly
contributed to his firing.
The New York Times reported
on the message,
which was sent on January seven. 20, 21.
Obviously, a pivotal day
right after the insurrection,
just hours
after those riots at the Capitol.
And he was talking about a video
he saw of Trump
supporters
beating up, in his words, and Antifa kid.
It was redacted in the Dominion
lawsuit, court filings.
But here's
what part of the Times says is behind
that big black box
at the bottom right of those filings.
A quote from Tucker's
text, it read, quote,
It was three against one,
at least jumping.
A guy like that is dishonorable.
Obviously, it's not how white men fight.
Yet suddenly
I found myself rooting
for the mob against the man, hoping
they'd hit him harder, kill him.
I really wanted them to hurt the kid.
I could taste it.
Then somewhere deep in my brain,
an alarm went off.
This isn't good for me.
I'm becoming something
I don't want to be. Close quote.
The Times is only able to unveil
the contents
of that text through interviews
with people
who spoke on the condition of anonymity.
CNN reached out for comment.
Fox declined.
Carlson did not immediately respond Back
with us
now, a writer
at large for The New York Times,
Jim Rittenberg,
who helped break this story.
We were talking about, you know,
there's no
you can't just say, yes,
this is ultimately what led to it.
But it's also the way that this came out
and how executives found out about this.
And we're seeing this message
right before they were
set to go to trial.
What is the impact that that had of
when they learned about this?
Well, as we understand
it, the board going
the trial was supposed
to start on a Monday
going into that weekend.
The board had asked to see
some of the redacted messages
in negotiations
about a potential settlement.
The jury is coming together. So the board
starts going
through the messages,
finds this one message
that they find very troubling.
Some senior executives were told
hadn't been focused on this message.
And it's not what you want to see
when you're going into trial.
A jury is being impaneled
and you're negotiating
what's going to be a potentially
very high number
to get out of this
so you don't
have to put something like this
in front of a jury.
But for this
text message being revealed to the
to the board
and Fox executives
the night before
the trial was supposed to begin,
would there have been a trial
and no settlement
I still
they were definitely working
toward a settlement.
And we were told that over the weekend,
Lachlan Murdoch,
one of the leaders of the company,
had told his lawyers,
let's start moving up on the number
to get out of this anyway.
I mean, that trial was going
to be potentially disastrous
on so many levels.
So but here again, you see,
when it comes to Tucker Carlson,
the issue here
is that he's he's playing an outsize role
in terms of problems in the case for them
when he's really not
a huge part of the case.
And that represents the trouble
with Tucker Carlson
to management at this point,
among other things,
and the questions
that are made
of why they did not settle sooner,
because all of this damaging information
came out, though
obviously this came out
as a part of good reporting.
Abby Grosberg
is the former Fox News producer
who is now suing the network,
and she was on with Anderson last night.
She was talking about
essentially the way things worked
and when it came to the fight
that we all watch play out
so dramatically
in Washington over Kevin McCarthy
and his bid to become House speaker,
she said this is what they talked
about behind the scenes
They believed that he could broker
who was speaker.
House speaker.
He wanted to do that live on air.
But Kevin McCarthy said no.
What do you mean
he wanted to do that live on air?
His plan was to have Kevin McCarthy
come on the show.
So fast forward to January 5th.
They start asking me to book
McCarthy on the show that night.
I had worked with him
a lot
when I was at Sunday Morning Futures
and had a relationship with his team.
That afternoon, Justin came in
and he said, here's a plan
Tucker is going to first have Kevin on.
Hear him beg and grovel.
Then we'll bring in Matt Gates.
And Matt Gates
will then kind of set his terms
Then Tucker will set his terms
that McCarthy has to agree to.
Carlson had terms in the terms terms,
and we're going to make this whole thing
happen on air
and save the Republican Party.
Now, fortunately, for McCarthy's sake,
he said no,
he speaks a level of influence.
I mean, that's why
this is in a way, so shocking.
Look at that
level of political influence
that Tucker Carlson had.
I mean,
he was a power in the part of the party
that it's the tail
wagging the dog right now.
And so to suddenly be cut,
it's really amazing.
But that shows also this symbiosis
that could happen
with the Fox prime time
and people in power
particularly Republicans.
We saw it with the Trump White House.
So here you see it again.
Yeah.
Jim, again,
as Kaitlan said, this came
because of good
reporting to you and your team. Kudos.
Thank you.
Thanks for having me.
Thanks for joining us.
Let's talk about this
and a lot more
with the co-founder
and editor
in chief of some of our Ben Smith.
Also perfect person to talk to.
So you just have this new book out
that we're going to talk about as well
called Traffic
Genius, Rivalry and Delusion
and the Billion Dollar Race to Go Viral.
You write a lot about the right wing,
the rise of right wing populism online.
So we'll get to the book in a minute.
But wow, this talk or text,
do you think that's why
this thing didn't go to trial?
I mean, this was the thing
that I think
every reporter was trying
to get and kudos to The Times
for figuring it out.
And,
you know, the thing
with a lot of the reasons
people say that Tucker Carlson was fired.
I think that there are a lot of viewers
who would not be totally shocked
to see him say something that racist.
But Fox
had been somehow in their own minds,
I guess, holding up this line that,
you know, all these allegations
of racism against Tucker and against Fox
were totally false.
And I do think this line about
this is how white people,
white men fired was was probably
may have been the last straw for them.
They're made it harder to
pretend anything else.
The rest of the text is
very dark and reflective,
but I think less likely to be the thing
that triggered this firing. Yeah.
And we haven't seen Fox or Tucker
Carlson comment on that, Tucker, so far.
We'll see what they say.
On your book,
you talk a lot about
I mean, we're talking about
how the media landscape is changing,
especially with Carlson's departure
from a huge slant on Fox News.
You talk about in this book, BuzzFeed,
which of course, you were editor
in chief of BuzzFeed News
and all of these sites
that depended on traffic
to go viral
and also how they built
so many of their company models
based off of Facebook.
But then once that stopped
being a venue for them to use it,
they shrunk essentially Yeah.
You know,
I was thinking about this
the sort of early days of building
social media and
and sort of hunting for traffic
when I was watching this Carlson thing,
because you know, a lot of that,
there was a perception
that the early Internet was,
among other things, left wing
like Facebook was.
Barack Obama visited Facebook
because obviously Facebook
is a Democratic institution
for college kids
that help Barack Obama get out the vote.
And I think a lot of people
in that early sort of online
world thought, well,
the election of Barack Obama
is like the culmination
of this new digital revolution.
And I think what
but when I look
back at
like, who is building this world,
in fact,
a lot of these early right
wing figures
Andrew Breitbart,
see, you've been and we're
you know, we're there all along.
We're very interested.
We're studying these digital media tools.
And as that
as the world
universe of people on social media grew,
you saw
you saw these conservatives
really make the most of them and channel
a lot of the anger
that you also see
in conservative cable,
just that raw often
racially divisive anger
and take that to really fuel
among other things
the Trump campaign in 2016
and that then Trump's
election is kind of the culmination
of that whole moment
when you talk about them
basically sitting down in the way
you describe at the white IKEA table
from the progressive Internet
team looking over the shoulder
this this really struck me on
page 43 wrote Obama
and Trump the Huffington Post
and Breitbart.
It's hard to imagine
they'd have much in common yet
both movements were rooted in part
and the new way of thinking about people
that came
when you saw them as traffic
obviously part
your title
measuring interest and intent
and channeling it into action.
What have we learned from
that as we look at a completely new media
landscape that in some ways
is reverting back
to the old what were deemed
sort of dinosaurs?
Yeah.
Going back into prominence
as some of these others go away Yeah.
I mean, there was
this early moment on the Internet
and I was, you know, marginally
a part of it.
But sites like Gawker
and BuzzFeed that I write about were,
you know, it's like you were flying
and suddenly you had instruments
and you could see everything
and you could see exactly
who was looking at what.
And when it came to
this kind of political stuff,
you could see, wow,
the most divisive stuff for
sometimes the most
the stuff,
the stuff that pushes
the edge hardest
is, is what attracts people.
And Facebook
then built this kind of a mechanism
you know,
where they were also
looking for engagement,
looking to say, well,
what do people stick to
and what will people comment on?
And often people comment
on the most outrageous thing,
the most shocking thing.
And there was a period
that I think alienated a lot of people
from these platforms
where that was where you open Facebook
and what you saw was the thing
most likely to outrage you.
And that was that was a choice
and that was not always a given.
There was this
it's hard to remember this now,
but there was a brief period
where people thought
they would be embarrassed
to share things like that
or they would be embarrassed
to get into shouting matches
on the Internet.
Clearly, not where we've ended up.
Yeah.
I mean,
I think we were very utopian about that,
among other things, right?
That when the media is social,
when it's open,
people are going to share fundraisers
for earthquakes.
They're going to share pictures of cats.
You know,
nobody would ever like
go on this big public space
and to start yelling about politics
because, like,
what a crazy, unpleasant thing to do
and everybody will hate you
that, you know, that didn't
exactly turn out to be
how human nature works.
Facebook also tweaked some dials
because they kind of saw
and liked the level of engagement
and stickiness
you got when people are screaming
at each other about politics.
But as Kaitlin points out, it's a choice.
It's our choice.
It's still a human choice.
It's a human choice.
But I think
with the one of the things we saw
was that the choices
these big tech companies make
and actually totally.
Yeah, I think it's more of the choice
that Facebook made on stuff like this.
The book's fascinating. Congrats.
Thank you. Thanks for having me. On.